[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler today we're
talking about ethical dimensions of
pirating digital products now that's
kind of a mouthful but you'll see what
we're talking about in just a minute and
this is one of those episodes where we
pick up a thread from a previous episode
I don't remember exactly which number it
was but we promised that we were going
to talk about this topic we got into a
side conversation that touched on
whether or not it was ethically okay to
download and share academic Journal
articles with people who otherwise don't
have access to those articles and that's
that's quite a few people and
um you know we we said we'd approach
this we're going to talk about it more
broadly the the issue of piracy see of
digital products so that covers a lot
more and I think that you know this
actually fits in really well with this
you sort of like declared mission of
wisdom for life to sift through
philosophy we're going to talk about
ethics to give you practical advice that
you can use in your everyday life
because this is something that a lot of
people are confronted with okay maybe
not necessarily on a daily basis
although I think some people are
but there's a lot of Temptations to take
stuff and I I will say myself that I
think that in some cases things that we
classify as piracy I view them as
okay not not great but they're the
product of
situations contexts that make it
difficult for people to have access to
information
but I'm not willing to say anything goes
what about you Dan I I don't take it
that you're like a Hoist the Jolly Roger
anything that you want to take from the
Internet is perfectly fine there's some
limits right
oh you could
call me Captain Hook or not no I think
there's definitely going to be a a
teasing out here this is
um you know something that usually gets
kind of turned into either a black or
white uh issue in which this is
definitely that is a false dichotomy
yeah you need to actually look at the
individual reasons for uh how certain
industries have put out or have changed
and how they come to be
um as well as just oh
as with almost any ethical contrary even
just you know stealing or murder there's
um questions of
was there any context in which this is
actually permissible and yeah unless
you're in a purely
um you know rules-based
um deontological kind of thing exactly
um system then you're going to have to
find there you'll always find some
places where these things are sometimes
permissible you know and I think you're
right that a lot of people
they take a stand on this that is very
black and white very
um it's either this or it's this or and
it often is quite hyperbolic we
solicited comments on social media and
YouTube about this very topic and I was
surprised by how many we got and how
vociferous some of these comments were
people saying things like this is
horrible or it's perfectly okay to play
to take anything you want you know there
were a lot of people on the extremes but
I don't think that's where we want to be
yeah two quote uh I think it's evil and
is a sin
that's very like that is a line in the
sand yeah I mean
we could say well what kind of scent is
this a big sin is this a little sin you
know what we call a venial sin but I
think the person who's saying that by
calling it evil to begin with probably
doesn't think that it's just a little
peccadillo you know a little sin essay
yeah they say right
it is a big moral issue and not a little
one yeah and this is this is something
that really we're gonna have to face
more and more because we see the
situations uh of that that would lead to
piracy or you know taking these things
changing
um from decade to decade and from year
to year right
oh you know as uh technologies that have
advanced it is allowed for you know
easier and easier copying you know you
think of like if you go back a couple
thousand years you've got you know
um uh whenever someone came into the
harbor and either uh Alexandria
Alexandria or if you went through the
boss first in Istanbul you'd have all of
your books confiscated they get copied
and then come back to you yeah and so
this you had to wait like a couple weeks
for this to happen and and now it's it's
instantaneous and the amount of work to
be done is minuscule you know almost
non-existent even in the age of the
printing press when they went from
having to hand copy things which was
very time you know labor-intensive time
intensive expensive to being able to
turn stuff out there were problems with
piracy then because you know you could
take somebody's book and then typeset it
in your own printing press and then
Churn it out you know additional copies
of it especially if it was a bestseller
right
um or to come to one of the the next
things we have here is like plagiarism
you know that that would be straight
plagiarism yeah but then like um
uh Don Quixote
um had a sequel that was written not by
Cervantes but some other guy who's like
oh I'm just gonna take this character oh
that's interesting create my own Don
Quixote stories and then Cervantes and
that becomes the best seller as well and
Cervantes is like what is this guy and
then writes his his own uh sequel where
he meets this guy who's pretending to be
Don Quixote that's interesting I didn't
know about that
um yeah
is that is that plagiarism or is that
stealing a character
and then because the guy is presuming
that would be like copyright yeah right
it would be as if I took so I love the
show The Venture Brothers I think you do
too don't you I do and so you know what
if I wrote fan fiction The Adventures of
the mighty Monarch
but then also wouldn't have sold it
yeah yeah
yeah and it's interesting too because
you can you can write fan fiction and
you can publish it online and if you're
not trying to make any money on it
they're probably not going to come after
you right right
but and then depending on where you live
that's either fine or not at least
legally yeah but so that's that's
another thing we should bring up too to
clarify right from the beginning we're
we're going to talk a little bit about
the legalities of this but we're more
interested in the ethical or moral
judgments that we can make about it
because there's a lot of times where the
legal system doesn't track the ethical
all that well I think this is in some
cases a good example of that and we
could talk about like you know several
different systems the legal system which
is decided by the courts and laws and
legislatures and then the economic
system and then you know we can talk
about the ethics of it
so that is going to lead us to not
seeing this in quite so black and white
fashion
um and so another part that we like is
adjacent but we're not going to be
talking too much but is uh reproduction
is study and so if you're an artist
especially a visual artist you you know
you're expected to copy the Styles or
even you know making you know your own
representations of Art in order for you
to learn to become an artist you know
I'd be kind of curious since I know that
you know quite a bit about coding and
you've done a good bit of it if
something like that exists within the
coding world not that you'd be like
looking at a masterpiece and then saying
okay I need to figure out how this
masterpiece program was put together or
something like that but actually like
looking at somebody's code and saying
here's an example of how to get
something done with you know these these
operators and this this code now you
write something that's not exactly the
same as this but something pretty
similar is that like a part of the
apprenticeship that goes on
it is actually both and so there's
definitely like if you look at like
stack exchange or on just GitHub
themselves like these these are people
are publishing code or code Snippets
about how to do things
um and then depending on where you're at
you'll have like some sort of voting
system to determine what is like a good
representation of this thing or not
what's a good actual type of code but
also if you like you know um if you want
to look at like the especially early
versions of Linux or
um uh C like Richie and oh I forget what
the other guy's name the the two guys
who invented C wrote a book on it
um you could you looking in their book
they have code snip and stuff like how
they're you know moving around pointers
and whatnot so there's there's
definitely certain pieces of code that
are well known they're like oh this was
masterful not only is it very clear but
it is also incredibly efficient
um and so there and and to a certain
extent these become well known as
algorithms especially for so it's not
specifically the code because a lot of
times like the languages we're going to
Define exactly how you're going to
present it yeah but the
um what we call pseudo code which is the
kind of the underlying idea that is not
that is a language independent
um about okay you want to be moving this
pointer from here to here to here or um
you know uh jetska's theorem which is
about traversing networks and trying to
figure out the fastest way
um to get through a network and how it
is the fastest way to Traverse the
network and then bring that information
back to it so you can know which path to
take yeah that's uh absolutely a similar
idea you know originally
um I'm really happy to hear that because
it shows that like it's across a bunch
of different uh domains domains
um I first started thinking about this
years and years and years ago when this
guy Paul Griffiths who was a Theologian
made an argument that we shouldn't we
should stop punishing students for
plagiarism because back in the Middle
Ages one of the ways in which you like
learned and this is talking not so much
about painting or coding or anything
like that but text was basically like
copying out other people's texts and
learning their dictum and their way of
thinking and stuff like that and he was
trying to make the case rather
implausibly that you know when students
are plagiarizing today that's probably
what we should view them as doing and we
have these weird very modern uh
viewpoints on intellectual property
which we shouldn't have but he did bring
up the idea that there's this kind of
like retracing somebody else's
staff and and it is intellectual
property all of this stuff is is IP but
that's that's a complicated concept one
that we throw around very easily but
when you know I think we saw this with
some of the comments people are like
what the hell is IP
[Laughter]
um um well before I hit IP you know yeah
it's also in novels like um there's a
story of a Hunter S Thompson writing out
the Great Gatsby and A Farewell to Arms
um word for word on a typewriter in
order to learn how to write like the
Masters yeah well that's interesting
yeah I I don't think that's something
that a lot of writers do but like that
is at least there are some who have
tried this you would have to pick the
right book and you're not sure whether
you've got the right book or not
so um two IPL intellectual property is a
um ooh one of my favorite words an
intersubjective reality that we've
created so the other subjective reality
yeah so we we should for yes our
listeners we should say what that is now
reality maybe we don't have to do too
much to Define that but inner subject
what is that but well first let's go
reality we know that is like the
physical world around us
um subjective reality is our individual
perceptions of reality around us
um but intersubjective realities are
things sometimes referred to as social
constructs are things that we have
created that
um
actually are not real but interact with
the world as if they are real so other
examples of this are money yeah and like
companies these don't think these don't
exist in reality but because we all
agree that they exist they affect
reality like real things yeah
so we should talk about the range of
things that we're going to discuss we're
already you know good ways in
um you know what can you pirate well I
mean we're not talking about Pirates
sailing around grabbing stuff or people
doing the equivalent of that like street
gangs going up to people and you know
grabbing books out of their hands or
anything but music music has been done
for quite a while
um I think a lot of people are familiar
with Napster and there were other
similar programs out there I used Kaza
before I put malware on my computer and
I had to get rid of it
um
yeah yeah and and every one of these had
kind of trade-offs but I will tell you
before the digital age it was super
super common for us to take
um cassette tapes and somebody's got an
album you ask them for that album you
take it back to your place you record it
you know you've got to turn table you
record it on your tape and then they
came out with like dual cassette boom
boxes and so if somebody had a cassette
of something that you liked you put
theirs in and you know you copied it now
there was degradation that went on with
this it wasn't like swapping MP3s you
know after you've copied a tape like 10
times
it's pretty bad quality you know but
that was you know an early type uh we
could also talk about television and
film a huge huge industry over in Asia
you know taking American uh Hollywood
films and uh producing pirated copies of
them but a lot of people also watch
things on sites you know I think with
one of the Game of Thrones episodes more
people watched it illegally streaming it
than actually what was it through the
HBO so yeah yeah wait viewership of that
is is crazy especially for incredibly
popular things and also if you can't
actually legally get it in your country
I think it's a lot better nowadays but
like really early yeah you know until
recently
um the walls between where media could
go legally were so slow like you'd be
months or years before you could legally
buy something in another country but the
internet moves at now speeds that's true
yeah I mean Customs could hold things up
the different formats from one country
to the other and then you know the laws
of the country could say it can't be
distributed unless it's like localized
or that's whatever yeah
yeah
um and then well we've got
um you know others Art and Design work
um software as well as obviously the
books um uh textbooks and otherwise that
we you know kind of really start about
and yeah any any sort of digital media
that can be represented as ones and
zeros because we live in a digital age
um now can be basically copied for
um
almost zero marginal cost copied and I
think another important part of this is
stored and then shared because if if I
just copy stuff and I keep it on my
computer and use it by myself okay that
is
copying something pirating it but it
really becomes more of an issue when you
have sites out there where you can go to
to download this right that that's when
the companies start getting worded
that's when the artists start getting
worried
um I was surprised to find out that
comic books graphic novels and Anime
there's a huge industry in pirating
those and that that's a big problem I
think you know we're going to talk about
like who who's actually negatively
affected I think in those cases the
producers are getting right out of their
uh their stuff
all right so
um I want to talk a little bit about
this um idea that's floating in this on
the Techno the world of technology of
like information wanting to be free and
so there's this seemingly paradoxical
situation which is information struggle
or called information struggle and so
the idea here is information wants to be
free and information wants to be
expensive so this is uh originally uh uh
quoted or attributed to this gentleman
by the name of Stuart brand who is uh
American writer and the editor of the
whole earth catalog
um and he's had a conference he's
talking and Steve Wozniak who's one of
the co-founders Apple was there and he's
referencing him he says on
on one hand you have uh you the point
you're making was is that information
sort of wants to be expensive because it
is so valuable the right information of
the right place can change your life on
the other hand information almost wants
to be free because the cost of getting
it out is getting lower and lower all
the time so you'd have these two things
fighting each other all the time
so when I when I talk about zero
marginal costs is like in the past you
would you have two different
um costs to make a product you have the
development cost and then the cost to
make one more of that thing yeah um and
so that's your marginal cost uh with
digital Goods the marginal cost of uh
making copies of many things is
approaching zero especially if the file
sizes are small like a a song is a
couple of megabytes that is you know
instantaneously transferred over the
internet on
but we've we've reduced this uh to the
point where
how can you make sure that you are kind
of like compensating those people that
are uh making the thing in the first
place while also dealing with the single
which was usually the stop gap which of
uh scarcity because it would cost you
enough then you had to ship the thing
um and which was kind of built into how
you would make sure that there is a
value add going back to the Creator
right yeah um when you've removed those
costs you know I think that the wants to
be expensive has two Dimensions right
there's the one in that actual quote
it's valuable the right information in
the right place changes your life so for
somebody this information is valuable
and I think that's completely legitimate
but you're bringing up what we could
call the the labor cost the investment
of the artist or the thinker or the even
just the coder who puts things together
and has had to use expertise which is
you know something that we can also
place a value on to produce this this
product right they've um
not just like Snap their fingers and
done it maybe it took them a year to
produce this game or this album or you
know write a book or something like that
but in the situation that we're in
um it looks from the outside like well I
can have this at an instant you know I
mean you think about a book for example
how much work it would be to copy a book
by hand and then you know get yourself a
printing press and set up all those
little tiles and stuff like that and now
we have PDFs that we just trade all over
the place and you know somebody had to
actually write that book somebody had to
proof jacket I mean when when there
isn't proof checking
um
the book really suffers uh so there's
been a lot of you know labor invested
and yet you know you can type in just
about any book that you want
type it into Google with PDF at the end
and somebody's probably already copied
it and now it can be pirated
is like one of the other things like the
right information the right place can
change your life like if you get the
right information you can learn a thing
that will put potentially materially
benefit you or your family
um going forward I've heard stories of
like
um people that learn how to uh hook up
generators and to win turbines that they
make from scrap from books and papers
that they found online right on to to
pump water and provide electricity
um for their the people that they live
with that's
um a great benefit
um and but you know because we have
um you know a market system that
incentivizes people making things you
have to have what we talked about
earlier this IP in order to make sure
that there is some sort of incentive for
people to continue writing and
distributing these things well and this
is a big problem in search Industries
like the music industry for example in
the United States and I think arguably
in the world has changed so radically
you know it's not as if it wasn't
exploitative in the past you know record
companies and managers and screw artists
out of money and super exploitative what
you could actually get an advance that
would allow you enough money to be able
to eat and have a roof over your head
and get the tour ready and produce an
album and for most artists that's that's
gone you know because people aren't
generally buying albums anymore what
they're doing is streaming things on you
know Spotify or apple music or pick
whatever else you want and artists are
getting paid very little amounts from
that unless they're like Superstars so
there's like a two-tier system Taylor
Swift's of the world right and and it's
you know when I talk to people in the
music industry they're like it's very
tough for young musicians right now
where you make your money is not so
selling albums the way it used to be in
the past and in record stores which are
mostly gone now it's
um live performances which you need to
get paid for you know not just do it for
exposure and then selling merch that's
selling merch is like one of the big
things and man that's tough you know and
if we if we don't see that changing and
I I don't see it getting better
we're probably going to have less people
who can actually make it as musicians
yeah
maybe we need like a musicians Guild and
they have like a a fund for new
musicians oh that's an interesting idea
yeah uh but that's going down a totally
different rabbit you know I will say one
other thing and this is a bit of a
rabbit hole when uh covet hit right
different governments across the world
set up different let's call them uh keep
people alive funds you know and so here
in the United States it took a lot of
scrapping just to get you know like well
we're gonna give everybody fifteen
hundred dollars you know in other places
um like for example Germany you know you
know they they did monthly payments to
to people and they included artists and
musicians which was incredibly important
you know rather than just you could if
you could demonstrate that you'd held
the job over here doing this sort of
thing if you're a freelancer
um they supported you and so you didn't
have to worry about starving whereas
here in the United States nothing like
that you know right I I thought I
believe I read something along the lines
at least some countries were buying like
80 of your paycheck right yeah yeah
which is you know definitely enough to
make sure that you're not going to
starve or anything yeah and you notice
they could do it it was feasible right
so we could write it if we wanted to we
just didn't have the political will
anyway back back from that rabbit hole
so
um
so let's talk about some of these uh
ethical questions to clarify
um so we've talked about this a little
bit this difference between ethical and
legal and sometimes this is referred to
as the difference between
um uh Mala and say and Mala prohibited
whereas Mala and say as things are bad
in themselves and Mala prohibitor things
are bad because Allah says something and
a lot of times these things line up
generally and but sometimes they don't
and so
um yeah I think agree oh go ahead oh
sorry please what's your example as we
were talking about before the show
um copyright laws have changed and Dan
actually looked up what the current
copyright laws and and
um it's you know it's changed
considerably from say what it was 20
years ago so some things are now illegal
that were legal years ago
and you know if you talk to the people
who are all about you know protect
copyright they they seem to think it's
an ethical thing oh you know the laws
are better because now they protect more
but really they stand in the way more
they they have some bad effects we could
say ethically
and they really just represent the
interests not so much of like artists I
would say but the people who profit on
the backs of the artists
and so
uh just to to clarify a little bit like
say
um something that's bad in itself is
like someone insults you and decide and
you decide to murder them that's I would
say that is bad in of itself I don't
think there's any ethical system
that really can do that because you
think like some honor-based societies
will say that yeah that's okay but
that's because they're wrong
they've got their they've got their
moral uh system skewed in in ways that
nowadays many people would consider
barbaric yeah I I I thought of
honor-based things just I was saying I
was like oh no you know what in that
thing it would potentially be okay
um
but um whereas I'm you know depending on
I guess where you're at like either
smoking or drinking or weed
um are
depending on where you're at on prime
example right yeah we live here in
Wisconsin which at this point in time
um buying and selling marijuana illegal
but most of our neighboring states it's
now legal to buy recreational marijuana
you know so you just got to Cross Iowa
yeah and I was only a small little
border
um so yes uh the next big thing is uh
whose moral or legal rights are violated
and to what extent
um and should they have those rights and
so yeah we've already talked about this
a little bit
really quite interesting like you know
for me when I hear the Disney
Corporation talking about copyright and
I think about all the things that
they've brought up over the years their
giant conglomerate personally I don't
care if somebody steals Mickey Mouse I I
don't care if somebody steals most of
Disney's stuff because Disney is making
money hand over fist on this and I don't
think that they're probably adequately
compensating everybody involved in the
uh processes in a lot of cases they're
just sitting on essentially intellectual
real estate that they happen to have
gobbled up I think you could say a
similar thing about people who buy
artists catalogs you know and expecting
it to get like them to die and then they
like they're
stuff is going to explode into value but
they just like stick it away in a vaults
I wasn't thinking so much about visual
art I was thinking about musicians
um so you know oh catalogs yeah
musicians will sell their musical
catalog which then allows it to be used
in commercials or what you know whatever
else you want movies great example as
well and now it's just somebody who's
the equivalent of like you know a
landlord who doesn't even bother to like
maintain the properties they just own
them and if you want to go through them
you got to pay you know so I so we would
call these rent Seekers yeah that's
that's because they're not actually
providing any new value they're just
extracting rents yeah I mean every once
in a while they'll aggregate things
together and they'll be like here's a
new and improved copy but it's usually
not all that new and improved you know
so who's whose rights should we care
about I I tend to think that it should
be you know we have to think about
consumers and whether they should have
access to a lot more than they they do
and we do have to think about the
producers but the producers are not the
big companies producing stuff except in
certain cases I mean I mean what do you
think about like software so if you've
got a Microsoft okay they've got all
these people working for them they maybe
maybe they could compensate them better
but it is Microsoft's product when
you're using PowerPoint or
teams or you know
at least right now
um there for the most part getting
compensated fairly well like if you're
going to be a software developer at
Microsoft you're making six figures or
more okay on so it's not
you're not gonna get like a 30k or
something pittance from this thing
unless you're I guess you could have
something that's part like an internship
and you might be paying whatever those
don't last very long in the software
World
um
but yeah like because software is so
large and is incredibly collaborative
um thing there is definitely going to be
more value and the larger you are and
the more market share you can kind of
gobble up due to at least a total of
partial monopolies
um you can extract more money and so
like the amount of money is actually
giving back to the developer is going to
be less than what you can actually
um would give it if you it was just like
here here's a profit share or something
yeah and we should point out that
Microsoft uh to be fair did get in
trouble with uh the US government over
monopolistic practices years and years
and years ago right uh they got I don't
know how much of a hit they actually
took by comparison to their revenue but
um uh mostly it affected Gates
um psychologically enough that it
changed its ways
no that that is like serious like he he
was put under deposition for that that's
true yeah it was not happy about that
and other Executives have been put on
the record saying it's like we don't do
that anymore because he doesn't want to
be proposed again
well if that works you know uh for them
I would have rather seen Microsoft
broken up personally yeah well so that
leads to some some other interesting
um
observations about this so we were
originally going to talk about
um like textbooks and academic articles
and we've seen massive Market
consolidation over the last I would say
like 30 years but especially in the last
10 years where there are companies that
own not just dozens but like
thousands of journals academic journals
and these are these are Big Box and it's
a really interesting model because it's
incredibly exploitative
um all around except for the companies
that are you know essentially owning
these journals like uh I forget how it's
pronounced elsevier or something it's
along those lines it's got got a kind of
weird name
um so the producers the people who are
doing the work to write academic
articles they're not paid for that it's
very very rare that you get paid for
writing an academic article
you're supposed to be you know
contributing to the profession it's
supposed to be part of your service but
that that made sense like 30 years ago
when most of the people in Academia were
tenure track they had the the
opportunity to you know have some job
security and a decent income and all of
that sort of stuff and that's not the
case anymore not at least not here in
America uh the majority of people who
teach in academic institutions are not
on the tenure track and they don't have
any sort of real protection they're
they're living rather precariously but
they're doing the work and the work is
not just writing the Articles it's also
reviewing the Articles which you don't
get paid for it's also editing some
editors do get paid some are volunteers
you know and so the on the producing end
it's you know there's there's zero cost
to the company that that owns the
journal now on the consumer end so
professors who need need to read that
stuff for their research libraries who
have to purchase all these bundled
together journals and most importantly
students all over the world who want to
have access to this stuff you know if
you go and you try to get an academic
article and your library doesn't have it
and most libraries don't have all that
much and that's if you're actually an
enrolled student you're not just some
you know Joe schmoe who wants to learn
something about Aristotle because
there's an interesting you know article
out there about it you got to pay
anywhere from like 20 to 40 dollars for
it now imagine that you need
30 articles to do the research in the
dissertation that you're working on you
know multiply that 30 times anywhere
from 20 to 40 and that adds up pretty
quickly so the only people that are
actually making any money on this are
the the companies that own the stuff and
to me
um
you know it's sort of like a monopoly
and it's it's sort of like Microsoft
except Microsoft is paying its workers
now and Microsoft is actually competing
to not you know Drive the software price
through the roof
but these journals are are really
soaking the consumer you know
right so this is really actually one of
these key things I was coming to think
about this yeah
I uh the idea of it if it is ethical or
not is how much the original person
that's creating this material are
actually getting compensated like we see
here with the the musical Thing
um we feel kind of worse about that like
piracy of this is is worse
um because it's taking away from the
ability for the musicians to actually
you know do the work and and produce it
and I'll make a living enough so they
can feed and uh house themselves yeah
um whereas when we're talking about
academic papers the people that are
doing all the work are not getting paid
at all for this product that is being
sold at rather exorbitant prices and so
people feel no problem about this thing
because it seems like these
um aggregators these Publishers are just
friend Seekers they have access to these
things they have exclusive access to
these things yeah and they get to choose
however much they want to rent it out to
them and it doesn't cost them anything
either to produce it or to distribute it
or like the amount of to cost to per
distribute it is
minuscule compared to the cost to
actually distribute it yeah I mean even
the cost to like license software can't
be too much right it's basically just
writing some code and you know making
people input some stuff and charging
them for it I will I want to change this
a little bit more and dig in on one
other academic matter so textbooks
Textbooks
exorbitantly For Students right students
are really getting soaked now in the
case of textbooks you can say that the
writer of a textbook is getting
royalties right so pirating I don't know
like uh intro to philosophy Anthology
um you're keeping this person over here
or maybe a couple people together from
earning an income on it
so maybe that's wrong right
um but the vast majority of the money is
not going to the author and royalties
it's actually going to the company that
that has published it and the company is
jacking the prices up over and over and
over again and I I know a lot of
students do use
um you know pirated PDFs you know it's
it's quite common I mean there is the
possibility of rental which is good
companies have students on that
but the rentals are like still like 60
of the cost of buying it new
that's true and you know this points to
another thing too we live in an era
and this is a little bit of a tangent
where a lot of the things that we
considered to be products that we would
buy are now no longer products that we
buy own and then can do what we want
with we're only renting them
from the producer all of her software is
like that right you will own nothing and
be happy and so it's it's not yeah on
this is not just software but it's even
Hardware
um so for example John Deere has gotten
to a lot nowadays because they're like
oh yeah we'll sell you this tractor but
the software is still ours and you can't
run your tractor without the software so
you don't actually own that thing you
own a license to that thing yeah and
they're trying to stick that into new
cars as well I saw that yeah behind
features like heated car seats so you
you want your heated car seats to work
oh pay us twenty dollars a month well
they'll turn it on for you now
um which most people balk at because
there's you know this really you know
this fair use of like
um I bought the thing I should be able
to sell this thing or
um give it away or modify it however I
want it's mine now I and they're like no
no we want that control forever so we
can have this recurring Revenue stream I
mean it's the same way with music too
once you switch to Apple music
um you know the first it was iTunes and
with iTunes you had MP3s that you were
actually purchasing from the iTunes
store and then you kind of owned
although iTunes could take them back and
you know then they it turned to Apple
music and
um there were a lot of artists who
actually
they lost their work because if you had
it in the format in your iTunes Apple
would go in and like suck everything up
into the cloud and then give you back
some things you know there might be a
different quality or a different
reporting of that thing but not the
thing that you had originally yeah
I I saw recently too that there was a
movie and I forget which movie it was
but Disney has redone the movie and
people who had downloaded the movie
previously in its original form
uh now have the Disney version which has
some scenes cut from it and you can't
get your original movie back
I know of people who will
both buy the thing from the like the
original people and then also pirate it
because they want to one try to support
the artists that are making it the first
place but they also wanted the ability
to do with that media how they want okay
without them stealing that background so
maybe there's a principle there right
um that once you buy something you
should be able to own it even if the
legal system and the economic system
that's changed says you don't really own
it you're just renting it or licensing
it all right
um and there's actually a number of laws
that are starting to get passed around
the United States specifically like
around John Deere saying
um you have to provide schematics and
the ability to do your own Diagnostics
because this idea of not being able to
own your own especially physical things
um just flies in the face people think
this is just stupid and not the way that
things should be done I think it's
easier to make the case with something
that's physical intangible like a
tractor a combine right then it is a bit
of music
although I would I would make the the
argument just because it happens to be
digital that if you buy something you
should have the ability to modify it
that just because it's a digital version
of the thing like if I buy a book and I
buy a an access to a PDF on like Amazon
or something I can write in the notes in
one and I'm not able to write in the
notes the other unless I like prints it
off or something but that might violate
the terms the use of the thing on and
now I don't actually own I own a a usage
of a thing and not the thing in and of
itself you know
um something that we haven't talked
about is games and it strikes me that
the sort of modification and usage that
we're talking about is very very common
in in games you know you think about
um Minecraft and all the mods that are
available for that and then you know so
I mean some of them are like changing
the entire world and how it works and
what the different entities are in it
and some are just as trivial as like I
want to have a brown belt to wear so I
have this skin or something like that
right but it all does involve
um modification of a digital product
right and this is like one of these core
things in you know in software uh when
we talk about hacking it is not always a
negative term it just means modifying a
thing in order for you it to do what you
want to do instead of how it was
originally designed so yeah think of
like someone like your your dad working
on his on truck or his Corvette or
whatever in the garage and he puts in a
different carburetor or he puts into
different pipes whatever that we would
call that hacking and so this is the
software is the same exact idea that
you're you're swapping out pieces and a
lot of these software bundles are now
software as a service yeah it is
something that you subscribe to and you
don't have the odd ability to interact
with it and here's the biggest issue
with this is a lot of these games that
you buy on that are software as a
service they are dependent upon some
sort of central service server to run
them to run the the multiplayer and if
they are multiplayer only games once
that server goes down you lose access to
your game and so this has happened quite
a bit on in the last year there's a lot
of games that people that had player
bases that can't play their games
anymore because the company decided it
was not economically viable for them to
run their servers anymore and decided
not to make this the code open source so
that the community wanted to create
their own servers on they were not able
to do that you didn't even have to make
it open source they just had to make a a
server client that people could run and
have people connect to
that's very interesting I mean imagine
if that the equivalent of that happened
with books where you know they just
suddenly took a whole bunch of books out
of circulation and you just couldn't get
them anymore you know
well and that is actually an issue with
um some books and music that um like you
just they stop producing them they
became rare like you know say a book
only had one running and
um one printing sorry and then you just
can't buy it anymore
um no one made a copy of it and it's
just it's a thing that you know about
that should be out in the world but you
have no legal way to obtain anymore
yeah so I think one of the things that
we can say is that
piracy
you know we could say that in general
it's wrong that perhaps even that's too
strong I think we have to look at it
industry by industry and perhaps region
by region you know so this might be a
good place to look at some of the things
that people said by way of comments and
I really like this one by uh zuhar
um ala jundi I lean positively towards
piracy and as I used to live in a
country that is heavily sanctioned Syria
pirating was and still is the only way
to have music Games Etc in some
political situations I also think that
with the economic inequality between
some countries pirating becomes a method
to close these inequalities at least in
entertainment and knowledge where the
price of a book that's twenty dollars is
literally somebody's whole monthly
income and the whole debate of open
science for poor universities or
independent researchers could be
discussed here so that's those are some
really interesting
points maybe you know the it's one thing
to be
um rich and and say you know as a hobby
I download PDFs of all these people's
books and then I circulate them around
to other people who are equally rich and
not we could all afford to buy the books
it's a whole other thing to be a
university student who can't afford to
buy books and whose library is not well
stocked and certainly not up to date and
see these cool things coming out that
you just you're locked out of
essentially economically you know you
know this this reminds me of two people
in the space on Aaron Schwartz and
Alexandria in bakyan
um who were well Aaron Schwartz was
um
yeah on really intelligent a gentleman
um he invented RSS uh as well as another
of other software
um uh pieces of software out there but
he's a lot like information was supposed
to be free especially concerning
um academic papers and so he was I
believe he was MIT and he went into a
closet and he downloaded it because the
the school had access to the journals he
was just Mass downloading all these
files and so
um quote here
um
by him but all of these actions go on in
the dark hidden underground it's called
stealing or piracy as if sharing a
wealth of knowledge where the moral
equivalent of plundering a ship and
murdering its crew but sharing isn't
immoral it's a moral imperative only
those blinded by greed would refuse to
let a friend make a copy and so he had
this really strong moral conviction that
this information should be free
um and this kind of continues on to
um alexandrian bakyan who created
science on our scihub which directly as
our reader here was talking about on she
is originally from Russia and on really
poor part of Russia and did not have
access to these things
um similar to our reader and so she
created a website that basically grabbed
the things that were published by Aaron
Schwartz and a whole bunch of others
jstor and um the put them on the web and
there are thousands of stories and those
represent many more of people who were
able to go to university or to improve
their communities through the
information being shared on for free
yeah and there's other sites that are
not quite as uh explicitly engaging in
that as SCI Hub but where there's a lot
of this going on you know academia.edu
tons and tons of papers that are
copyrighted that you can find there in
philosophy there's uh fill papers which
is at least in philosophy starting to
replace
academia.edu a lot of people upload
their stuff there as well and you know I
mean that might go away down the line we
can also think of archive.org which is
getting just hammered these days with
all sorts of legal attempts to shut them
down and they are they are so invaluable
the stuff that they make accessible to
to all of us that we probably couldn't
get in our our local libraries even if
they're good University libraries
um there is something I wanted to go
back to with the the Schwartz quotation
I think you're right he's he's seeing it
as not only
not wrong but the right thing to do and
even
a required morally required thing to do
but I I think one of the things that's
important in this he says uh it's called
stealing or piracy
um as if it were the moral equivalent of
plundering a ship and murdering his crew
so these are now these are analogous
terms right these are metaphors for
what's going on when you're downloading
a PDF of a book you are not a pirate
jumping across slashing somebody's face
open and you know throwing them off of
the the ship and then taking their stuff
you're you're just you're downloading a
PDF and then if you share it with
somebody you know there's there's
something out there that circulates
around that I ran into a while back it's
all PDFs and video files and it's called
the Alexandria project and people will
copy the entire archive and then move it
around it's obviously philosophy stuff
and kind of Continental stuff as well
but
um you know is that really pirating is
that really
um murdering a crew or something like
that no it's I mean a lot of the people
that you know these these books are
they're already dead they're not they're
not I mean you could say Well they're a
state should derive an income but a lot
of times they they don't have it a state
um so I think that this language thing
is really quite interesting and I think
I think Schwartz is probably right about
that at least when it comes to academic
articles
maybe textbooks
um
I don't know do you think this applies
to software to games to
film as well or not
as an immoral imperative to shirt
yeah I mean would we say there's a moral
imperative to share
um the latest episode of pick whatever
show you know succession was just
wrapping up right and so
um you have to have HBO to watch it now
it's not that expensive to get HBO but I
can see how some people could maybe not
have it
I don't know it's it's hard to say that
getting to watch succession
has the positive impact on your life
that the sort of examples you were
bringing up before about reading
academic articles or books that that you
know could improve your life or working
on your tractor you know yeah I would
say like in general probably not I would
say that there's definitely some media
out there that's on raises to that level
um
I'm trying to think what would be an
example of that I I I'm trying to think
like maybe like a documentary on like
gone here MLK or something okay yeah
yeah even a dramatization of that
um something along that line
um
there there might even be things that
are copyrighted that are are really
important that are very very new
um and it's kind of it would you can
maybe make an argument but like it's
it's lesser it's the as well as you know
it goes back to this argument of like
how well are the creators of these
things actually getting paid yeah so for
example there's um
oh a disco Elysium which was an
independent
um development company made this game
called disco Elysium it got all these
um great accolades but
um their developer was kind of
backhanded they had a really bad
contract with them in order to get
enough money to actually make in the
first place
um they've I believe that the publisher
has basically taken total control over
that and the developers are getting no
more money from the sale of this even
though it is a massive success uh
interesting and so the question is
um if the money isn't going to the
people that um made it and they made it
in the last
couple years
um then
what what is the moral imperative
besides like you know I had the law in
my line and someone signed a bad
contract yeah yeah
um
yeah I mean saying saying oh well you
should have read the contract better and
you you know you deserve what you get
that seems off right because you could
say well why are we in such a regime
where people can so routinely get
screwed out of the fruits of their labor
you know maybe
okay like obviously we don't live in
Star Trek but like this is the
difference between like how Star Trek
that's like Stark is like you do things
to share it because like your value in
the society is like your clout about the
things that you do yeah basically
um and and because all material uh
wealth is already dealt with like you
know they've got uh replicators and
they've got rid of money so everyone can
live and do whatever the heck they want
um and but we have to live in the system
where you you either make money or you
start I was just laughing because we've
been watching a lot of Deep Space Nine
and in Deep Space Nine there are a lot
of Ferengi characters and the Ferengi
characters are constantly talking about
gold press Platinum which is their means
of exchange and how many bars of it and
I guess there's other measures as well
you know so in the in the Starfleet
Universe yeah nobody needs money because
everybody gets provided for but the
Ferengi are much more ruthless and it
seems like the Ferengi they trade with
everybody else and everybody else
understands that you better have your
gold pressed latinum or you're not
getting the stuff that you want
um and it's really interesting to see
how their motivations of the characters
of the Ferengi are in stark contrast to
those people in starplate
yeah you know again we could do another
spin-off episode about the rules of
acquisition which have been charted out
you know and there's quite a few of them
and do they constitute a coherent
philosophical perspective or not and
that that might actually be a good place
to to wrap up uh you know we haven't
like come up with a definitive ethical
solution of the issue of piracy but you
know we hope that we uh provoke some
people into thinking a little bit more
deeply about it and uh we do have more
than one we came up with a a selection
of of quotes that we'll go out on so do
you want to lead us out Dan yeah I guess
I'll add one more on my big data
professor in college says
um the best answer is usually it depends
but
we leave you with the words of first
Neil Young it doesn't affect me because
I look at the internet as the new radio
piracy is the new radio that's how music
gets around and from Aaron Schwartz
information is power but like all power
there are those who want to keep it for
themselves
[Music]
foreign